[THEME MUSIC]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Read Feed is an app that just
graduated from Google Play's
early access beta program.
Now, read the post
to learn about how
they use the program, to
solicit feature requests,
identify bugs, locate new
and optimize existing target
markets, as well as build
a sizable reader community.
This is a great article
for fitness app developers.
It outlines three
recommendations
towards building a more
valuable fitness app
experience with examples.
Take a look.
A Style Transfer
is the technique
used by some new
phone and web apps
to help you render your
favorite picture in the style
of a well-known work of art.
This a really cool
post on our research
blog about going a step
further by combining
many different styles to
explore unique mixtures
of well-known artists and
create an entirely unique style.
If you're into machine
learning, it's a fun read.
You can now treat Google Cloud
Storage like a file system
with our new
PowerShell provider.
It's included in
the latest release
of cloud tools for
PowerShell, and lets
you use commands like
CD, copy, or even cat
to navigate and manipulate
your data in cloud storage.
More details are on the post.
We now have support for
Windows Server 2016 Data Center
Edition, the latest version of
Microsoft's server operating
system on Google
Compute Engine, which
means you can launch instances
with Google Compute Engine VM
images with Microsoft Windows
Server 2016 pre-installed.
For the list of all
versions we support
and some getting started
notes, check out the post.
And that's your quick update
about what's new and cool.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[THEME MUSIC]
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
For some of our past
episodes, click here or here.